this is a very important video to happen
today
one of the tiers that i have on my
patreon you can do one-on-one meetings
with me depending on your situation
depending on if you really need help or
not this is tier four right
costs 500
five hundred dollars to do a one-on-one
meeting with me people
to do a one-on-one meeting with me what
who are you
he's a youtuber
okay
what does he do
he does like basketball streams and he
talks about like soul and spirituality
okay
five hundred dollars
i mean beacon charge whatever you can
charge 500 if you wanted to
people would play so it's this one
particular young guy who's going to see
this video he blocked me so i posted
have been doing a one-on-one meeting
with him but he hit me up he said all he
wanted is a birthday shout out and i
told him like man
let's link with a one-on-one meeting so
i can chop it up with you for your
birthday i could be like dude get your
money's worth you just paid 500 just for
me to shout you a birthday shout out so
i'm telling him let's get you know put
your little fears to the side basically
i sent him the link so we get ended up
getting a zone meeting and i guess like
when you
do the the first thing i noticed me i'm
reading his energy it's his birthday the
[ __ ] look depressed and you 16 years
old smoking a cigarette something i
added up what the [ __ ] have you been
through in life in high school
most teenagers are depressed high school
to some degree you see a teenager
smoking cigarettes i think almost half
the teenagers i knew were smoking high
school what you go through
high school
that's what he's going to win he's going
through it
his algebra [ __ ] is hitting him hard
i i told him straight up
if it's anything you want to get off
your chest or me to help you with tell
me right now because once i'm gone i'm
gone you get what i mean
dude straight up put his pride to the
side and he kind of got a little
emotional dude told me he been
this is no joke he told me he'd been
for the past four years
right the blurred out world did is that
the word is uh self-deletion
you know the guy was having
self-deletion thoughts one of the things
i told him when he told me that i told
him you don't have to feel like
embarrassed or something to tell me just
because i help people with this [ __ ] on
a regular basis
emails etc that's my whole point of
making a patreon is to help you i'm and
i told him like i could tell something
is bothering you and he did not bro it
took me like 10 minutes for this [ __ ]
to literally open up and tell me what
why he
so i want y'all to hear this real quick
i'm about to get straight to the court
of what he told me
he said when he was in the 7th grade he
ended up having a situation with a
couple guys at his school
now it turns out his mom
has a only fans his mom had him when she
was 15 years old he basically said he
found out that his mom
was like doing that type [ __ ] by him
watching
watching porn and coming across his mom
he said this is how he found out now
this [ __ ] is weird he even told me he
built some type of fish with just
checking on his mom content oh my god
oh
my god
[Music]
my god
all right
he basically told me in the seventh
grade it's these two guys that he never
really got along with but they was in
the same class he said one of the guys
ended up finding out about his mom he
said they used to massacre and hold that
[ __ ] against him they used to always
make jokes about it they used to play
her audio out loud of her moaning
like some kitty childish
all right this is where it gets worse
for this [ __ ] the whole school ended up
finding out that his mama a hoe
and deep down i want to ask him who the
[ __ ] is your mom but how am i gonna ask
him this
you [ __ ] up
anyways
anyways
all right how much you play this bro
let's get through this he said when the
8th grade came he's completely stopped
going to school when he used to just
like go to his grandma house so after
him telling me this entire story about
everything that happened at his school
far as his mom being a porn star etc i
asked him straight up
i said dude
who's your mom like after he broke down
and told me this so for five hundred
dollars you can have your personal stuff
used for content
it's very difficult to make me
speechless
but who's your mom though i find it so
fascinating that someone's so obsessed
with spirituality is this lacking in
self-awareness
imagine somebody telling you a teenager
most of all with severe mental health
issues is telling you about this stuff
in a moment of privacy and confidence
right and they're telling you why
right and your main thought is to engage
in the exact same behavior that made
that made him
want to self delete
if that's not bad enough
against this kid's wishes
you take his story you take so many
details about his life that make him
identifiable and you post the [ __ ]
online
and put ad dollars on it so you've
monetized the teenage kids
that is crazy on so many [ __ ] levels
that is insane
spoiler
you
i haven't watched the video oh my god
like after he broke down and told me
this
that's all i asked bro who's your mom
that's so that's all i said
who's your mom like dude i'm not trying
to look her up to jack i already
probably jacked off to the [ __ ] in the
past i'm not trying to do nothing i just
remembered that he started the story by
saying that the dude blocked them
i just remembered and i was like oh yeah
i might just hit her up and tell her
what she did
how she's affecting you right now she's
still doing that in her 30s
when i asked him who's his mom
he blocked me
yeah [ __ ]
yeah
yeah he did
hey you don't get why you don't
understand why
you don't see it
why he blocked you
the [ __ ] don't exist on my patreon no
more
he's gone
i don't know what happened to him
and this video is for awareness purposes
i'm not making fun of him i ain't saying
no names i don't even know who he is or
his mom is somebody watching this can
probably identify this kid it's not that
difficult and now they're gonna make fun
of the fact that this guy's in your v
okay i can't watch any more this i don't
even know if it gets worse i don't think
it's better i don't know i don't
you're a clown you might be one of the
biggest [ __ ] clowns i've ever seen on
this platform and we our business is to
cover clowns i have not seen clown [ __ ]
on this level in a long [ __ ] time
listen you're
he didn't want to talk about it you
pushed him
he just wanted a birthday shout out you
pressured him
to open up to you
then you listen this whole traumatic
story while he's crying he's doing all
[ __ ] and you engage
on my days all my days
i never seen no [ __ ] like this never
listen there's a discussion to be had
about only fans and parents and how it
affects the children that's a separate
discussion that i'd be willing to
entertain on a different day but right
now the only thing about i think i'm
going to think about is the fact that
this [ __ ] is a content creator
who took somebody's money so they can
turn them into content and trauma
traumatize a teenager that's the only
thing i can think about you have any
thoughts no no none
no none whatsoever you said what you
said
that is crazy that yeah at the beginning
i was finding problems and it got worse
as i was listening to it
and yeah no i have nothing i have
nothing else to say you said everything
you said
uh no and if i talk it's just gonna be
redundant so how about we just hand it
there
let's just finish it there we're good
i'm good
what you're gonna add you're gonna add
some [ __ ] yeah it's just there's a
fascination for you between like this
whole like pseudo
pseudo
uh wow pseudo spiritual people
who often times seem to have zero
self-awareness lack of self-awareness
let me say this
i do instagram live sometimes and we let
fans come on and fans come on they share
whatever okay
and i've had fans tell me like bro i
hear voices and stuff like that and i
don't know i have a hard time adjusting
to people um you know i say
go see help there's no help go seek
professional help not to be like
it's not my lane i'm not the one
i cannot help you i'm not the one and
oftentimes i feel like because people
have such proximity with content
creators or at least they feel like they
do they come to them with these personal
problems that these content creators are
not fit to help you with and sometimes
these content creators are too [ __ ]
stupid to realize the limits of their
capabilities so let's start giving them
medical advice or all this other stuff
it's like brev know your lane
know your lane you got people out here
with serious clinical issues who are
going to folks who are not only
unqualified but are absolutely arrogant
about how little they [ __ ] know and
then actually make the situation much
worse if this kid was thinking about
self deletion before imagine how much
he's thinking about it now
so content creators have to be
especially responsible in regards to
like one-on-one conversations and
thinking you can do [ __ ] you cannot do
and also to the public stop going to
these people for your advice on things
that like
i get it you need to talk to somebody
and that's okay
but it's also okay to actually need help
from people who are trained in these
fields
people come to me and ask me for
electrical advice on their building
[ __ ] i've never [ __ ] crossed any
wires
why would you come to me
so you guys also have some
responsibility in that regards but this
is a teenager jesus christ and he didn't
even want to come to you for advice you
pushed it out of him
500
from a teenager you know what i like you
know what i like that we have a rule
that we don't talk to underage people
oh yeah yeah if you're a kid i screwed
him up we flushed that [ __ ] out real
quick every time they joined the live
how old are you 18
[ __ ] you lying get off i'll boot them
off so quickly
we don't want to we don't do that no
cause i'm not your dad or your mom and i
don't want to take on that role we don't
do this no
so i don't know anything else you want
to say no